hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the impossible
quiz book also known as the game that's
gonna make me look like an idiot and the
follow-up to the impossible quiz 1 and 2
now this is made by the same guy of
course so it's the same basic principle
and it's gonna make me look stupid and
apparently this is just chapter one of
many and unfortunately if I ever want to
see those chapters I most likely have to
beat this probably not though but I'm
armed with my incredibly brilliant mind
and this one seems to have some nice
animations to it it's almost delightful
Close Encounters of the Third Kind I
know there was something about a cat in
this well there it is that's that's cat
right there that would be a cat licking
itself this is just no no you couldn't
don't take it don't you dare it's too
powerful it's too okay how do you start
an impossible quiz painfully carefully
hey which of the following is a shooting
star that's clever that's clever that's
clever right there I like that that's
pretty clever ah shooting star what time
is my dentist's appointment how would I
know this why would I know when your
dentist appointment is 2:30 that's a
pretty respectable time what do you call
a female lemur
a fever would be funny miss madam a
ballbag what else what are you talking
about femur ah I know how you think I
think could you please point me towards
eastward eastwards wait a minute let me
think about this
now stop doing that I don't mean to stop
what am i doing you need to stop and let
me think there's got to be something up
dammit that points eastward no damn it
come on oh that one oh the other one
okay what is the best thing since sliced
bread cancer France turnips wasps
no God oh come on
oh it's not that either I don't know who
died know what's the best thing since
sliced bread that doesn't make any damn
sense
Oh what
why wait W what's the best thing since
sliced bread what what are you talking
about what is this bird flu sick as a
parrot elite ill eagle good
what is the seventh letter of the
alphabet wait a minute dang on this
question seems familiar
what did I'm not saying it wasn't ABCD
efg you son of a [ __ ] oh the alphabet
Oh one two three four five six seven
eight hi you press the button on my
thing that is a dead pig reminds me of
amnesia a machine for pigs which is the
following you spelled correctly whoa I
swear this is harder than the last one
because this one doesn't even make sense
it did in the beginning banana doesn't
live big bling Buju sperm count one two
three four five six seven those are some
creepy-ass sperms fertilize oh wow
how many letters in Assassin's
none [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
why why for Oh how many different
letters okay one two three four five
why's this one green hey that was a
pretty little whatever that was what do
feed eat for breakfast good series toast
bacon both all bacon corn flakes oh no
what if we need to feed eat anything
defeat eat feet defeat defeat wasn't why
is that green why is that green what
Afridi what do any of us eat what okay
how does this quiz make you feel angry
good answer this question please press
the long one spacebar you won't even
know what I pressed that was a blue fish
one fish two fish red fish blue fish so
what about that that's the thing for me
possible quiz to who you want from me
what does it mean what does it mean what
do I do
seriously what the hell do I do cuz
there's no idea you you [ __ ] lovely
ass fish huh
I press the button and it happened which
one did I press I was matching
everything where can you find the
meaning of life forty-two No
the dictionary Oh
which of the falling would win in a
fight a badger a wasp but in a match
that's because the flight is another
word for match wrong to the falling
would win in a fight at in one or I'll
attend that I guess that is a cat but
okay
okey-dokey yeah this is this is really
elegant okay about two two point one oh
I got something oh I knew there had to
be something with it you're solid I
present okay I press the button here but
I'm not sure which one see oh okay all
right let's keep going at in about two
there yo [ __ ] one I knew it what do
you call a baby yogurt yog late' milk
cuz yogurt is basically boil milk
chocolate I should have known 27 what oh
my god no no no oh god I don't know what
you want from me whoa I guess under
there my things
Oh y'all would need to count Oh God
I needed to count how many was happening
so that I wouldn't die
ok 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15
16 17 18 boom got it what what it just
so happens in my mouth was there fart
why is the sandwich someone peed on it
where's your fascia stupid raining crab
juice why would I know
why would I know they said why is the
sand wet why would the sand be wet why
wouldn't the sand be wet it's by the
ocean it would make sense at this end
with wet sometimes unless it was in the
desert you know to be true desert that's
what it could be here what it couldn't
be tell how about you shut the F up yes
seaweed seaweed so the sand is wet
because the seaweed on it really you're
questioning your own question this is
please don't presses what
I'm not mad at you I'm mad at the
situation and those that suggested this
game okay yeah then we stopped being a
bit of douche how about you let me
continue in a correct version yes oh hey
how is that even possible I mean this is
a huge mass of water
how could he urinate on a beach that's
what my question was in the beginning
that's a good point I'm not pressing
that button the key could you screw
yourself okay it was bad point you're an
idiot an [ __ ] okay oh no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no god damn
it
party's so hard to click no no no no oh
my god I yelled at it loud enough and it
decided to let me live but I will if she
lives okay how do I deliver how do I
deliver delivery delivery what do we do
okay I'm back again but I don't know why
I don't know what I need to do doc yeah
Deb Oh what oh oh oh what what what what
the deliver deliver click deliver ha ha
ha ha
what is this tasty pink stuff brains in
a pot wonk don't walk Danka a yog wit
well one of the glasses before was what
the baby yogurt an is the yog with soap
okay March it is March but how do I
March there are a hundred pennies in a
pond what a waste
meeting jubilant know what David mean
there are a hundred pennies in a pond
pennies in a pond there no the producing
oh there are hundreds more pennies in a
porn jar
uh mr. Wayne is a hundred pennies and a
pawn some men just want to watch the
pennies burn no you let's why why
explain why explain why oh god the timer
stop
yeah that was probably a waste but I
wasn't paying attention because I was
still even flammer dwith your previous
question what occurs once every minute
twice every moment but never in a
thousand years
um the letter M what is wrong with this
question you had a stroke while you were
writing it Oh God all right never mind
yeah that's still wrong but whatever you
wrote it with your penis wrong with this
question
you wrote it with your left hand okay
what do you call a man with two donkeys
by asked by asked by asked two asses oh
come on what am I supposed to do
something here do you need my help with
something she'd really need my
contribution this one all right do I
just have to wait until you're done my
viewers really don't deserve to see this
hairy butt and butt crack peeing all
over the screen and why are you shaking
it like that what is the possible cause
I don't think I want to know what's
going on it P the letter P ha ha clever
answering this question may required
about ball movement some bowel movements
trust me it doesn't yep okay baby this
onion
Oh Oh bat moves bow
I probably shouldn't happen oh god no
okay bringing out a little kitty cat
you're about to get zapped 70 Zippity
zappity exhibitors - come on beat the
thing
don't be some trick on me yeah the
square root of all evil is impossible
quiz haha
bacon goes up Portia places pork pigs
fly what niblets click on the door the
quiz touched and my cinemas area hello
please your other
what do cannibals do after they've
dumped their girlfriend what what let's
just assume you're gonna be totally
immature here and assume that the
cannibal is dumping their girlfriend
after they ate them and now that means
die oh wait no what what do i do what do
i do what do I do
what do we do
living in Wahpeton I didn't know I
needed to do this you son of a [ __ ]
yay-yay worms
the answer is type cat what no other
typecast day oh wait oh no anybody
anyone works anyone works okay that's
much better
oh I thought I was out of time typecast
type CAS no no that's what you told me
to do
hahaha fix the underground oh wait a
minute
tick tick tick tick it okay okay what do
i do what do i do what do I do
I can click what do I do what do we do I
don't know what to do I'm gonna keys vud
debate something unstable I have keys on
my keyboard to those guild
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
I thought I had it yeah okay all right
no dutiful versus hon it's not a fartist
yeah how do we do this one what do I do
and we sign you what do I do it which I
do okay thank you
now what the hell do I do I can't click
on him well I can click on them but they
don't do anything well wait a minute
wait a minute whoa I see something I
just need to click on this wait a minute
what
okay
Oh ah there we go
I got it you don't need to rub it static
not like that desktop it is it life on
Mars I don't know how do I tell I don't
know how do I tell oh wait we know there
was something there
no oh really you're gonna be about fart
jokes again oh no no no no no no I can't
okay fart that's good I like fart for
good what do I do okay that was rather
cruel you douche the poor cat I don't
really care anymore this that cam made
this quiz I did and now I never have to
do it ever ever again right well I hope
that my suffering was worth it if it was
let me know in the comments below and if
you want me to see me do the next one
leave a like to let me down
or just wanted to do it so anyway thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video